all right guys bang-bang got a bunch to
talk about this morning I don't even
know where to start with the story
yesterday late in the afternoon Rhode
Island is there's an article in
Bloomberg and the title is Rhode Island
police
to hunt down New Yorkers seeking refuge
and the article starts with a paragraph
Rhode Island police began stopping cars
with New York plates Friday on Saturday
the National Guard will help them
conduct house-to-house searches to find
people who traveled from New York and
demand 14 days of self quarantine it
then goes on to state that National
Guard members will be stationed at the
TF Green Airport Amtrak train stations
and at bus stops the citizens soldiers
will be following up with people at
local residences the maximum penalty for
not complying they find a five hundred
dollars and ninety days in prison so
here's the problem right I get it
coronavirus is very real the threat is
real we should do everything we possibly
can to try to prevent the spread but we
also have to understand that a health
crisis is not an excuse to erode civil
liberties right we cannot allow them to
use them being the government to use a
health crisis to erode civil liberties
or to violate your constitutional rights
and so this is really really bad I mean
people should be outraged about this the
governor of Rhode Island wanted to close
the border to say I don't care if you're
an American or not you can't come to our
state right that is unacceptable as an
even as a thought and she was stopped by
her lawyers the lawyer said that would
be unconstitutional you can't do that so
instead where they ended up is now what
they're doing is literally they're
standing on the side of the road and
anyone with a New York license plate
gets pulled over right that is not legal
you are not allowed to do that that is
not legal and so not only are they
proactively looking for people with New
York license plates driving
along the highway now what they're doing
is they're enlisting the military the
National Guard to literally sit at the
airport at the train stations the bus
stops etc and they're enforcing these
rules the problem with this is these are
military patrols this is the police
patrolling American citizens they can
spin it however they want they can use
whatever language they want but this is
not legal
right this is a violation of people's
constitutional rights and on top of
pulling people over simply because they
have New York license plates and on top
of having the military patrol
transportation centers they're now going
a step further and they're saying the
police and the military will go house to
house right this is what happens in war
is we go house to house that doesn't
happen in American communities but all
of a sudden we are going to use a health
crisis as a way to violate
constitutional rights to erode the civil
liberties and what I mean by this is
they're doing two things it sounds like
one they're asking local residents are
there any New Yorkers here think about
that for a second are there any New
Yorkers here anybody from New York
showed up recently and then two is they
know that people have vacation homes in
certain communities and then they're
gonna go to those homes and patrol those
areas looking for those people we've
seen this happen in history and it's
never ended up well never right this is
not the free democratic world that we
live in that's protected by the United
States Constitution this is something
out of China or Hitler's time this is
not what you expect him to see in the
United States and so the big problem
with this entire situation is that it's
bad leadership right you've got a
governor who literally said I want to
close my border something that is a
violation of the Constitution and when
her lawyer said you can't do that they
then said okay why don't we set the
military and the police on patrols to go
find people that's not okay either and
of course all the civil liberty
are freaking out right absolutely up in
arms over this but it doesn't matter
they instituted stopping cars on the
highway yesterday this morning they're
starting with all sorts of
house-to-house searches military at the
transportation centers etc it's just
unacceptable and I think the American
population has to pay attention but now
that's the big thing we have to pay
attention and understand that in times
of crisis there will be attempts to take
back civil liberties to erode the
constitutional rights if you go back
look at 2001 right with 9/11 the Patriot
Act etc led to all of the electronic
surveillance that we've seen right if
you go back to 2008 the issues right and
now we're seeing it again and so this
isn't just a rhode island problem right
we see that the federal reserve asking
for relief from the Sun Sun Shine Act
which basically means that they can hold
MIT meetings at the federal reserve and
not tell the American public what
they're talking about they don't have to
keep minutes they don't have to tell you
what it was talked about in the meeting
right again taking less transparency as
the path that they want to pursue not
more transparency then you go do
something like Rhode Island here and
what you're seeing them say is we are
literally going to use our military and
our police to patrol our state in order
to find these people there's no
difference in saying I want to keep a
person out of this geographic region
because they're from Mexico or China or
South America or South Africa or Europe
or Canada or New York City you're
preventing the freedom of movement of
somebody based on where they are from
and it's just a violation of the
constitutional rights and I understand
that there's a health crisis
I actually agree that we should be doing
things to prevent the spread of the
disease or the virus the problem is that
the rules don't apply to the two most
susceptible groups so they create these
rules and they say if you're a citizen
you can't do this but by the way our
health care workers are public health
servants or law enforcement they're
allowed to move as at free
we'll even if they've been to New York
so even if they are likely to have the
virus and to be bringing it back in to
Rhode Island they're allowed free
movement and on top of that we're then
gonna send the police door-to-door
well how do you think the virus gets
spread there's I think 500 New York
Police Department although I'll check
right now I think it's 500 NYPD
coronavirus over 500 new york police
department members test positive for the
corona virus there's five hundred cops
in New York who have the corona virus
and if you send those cops door-to-door
to go check on your population you're
likely to increase the spread of the
virus this is absolute stupidity showing
its face because one you're gonna
violate the American Constitution two
you're going to take away the civil
liberties of your population and then
three you're gonna take some of the most
at-risk people to have corona virus and
then send them door-to-door to go check
on people absolute absurdity and so a
lot of people will say well don't
complain about it tell us what you would
write I'm not a governor right I don't
have to deal with that situation but if
I was rather than telling people what to
do
be a leader inspire people to do the
right thing
don't use your military and your police
to do it if instead you said hey this is
a national health crisis and people are
going to die we have to come together
and we have to do this and use the
inspiration of the American people and
explain to them the gravity of the
situation and get them to do the right
thing Americans want to do the right
thing but they don't want to live in a
police state they don't want to live in
a country where the military and the
police are patrolling centers of
transportation simply so that we can
implement these ridiculous laws or think
about the governor wanted to literally
close down her borders and got told no
you're not allowed to do that so that
was the starting point and they walked
it
back all the way to okay we'll just use
the military and police to go house to
house we know where people have been
casing homes so we'll send the military
in the police there oh and on top of
that if you're driving down the road and
you have a New York plate
whether you're a Rhode Island resident
or not we're gonna pull you over we're
gonna question you that's not legal that
is not legal and a health crisis isn't
an excuse to go ahead and violate the
American Constitution so I think a lot
of people just need to keep an eye out
now or in a health crisis that's causing
an economic crisis there will be attempt
to overreach in incredible ways right we
saw the Department of Justice asking for
to be able to detain people indefinitely
right no timeline on it no no right to a
fair and speedy trial etc so we just
need to stay aware and understand that
in times of crisis there will be these
attempts and people need to speak out
people need to say this is not right
because if you do not speak out
eventually those rights are eroded away
and so you just need to make sure that
you're paying attention I'll take some
questions this morning I'm gonna stick
around for a little bit so if you have
any questions go ahead and shoot them in
the comments here but I will do my best
Rhode Island has long been a police
state yeah look III don't know I have no
opinion about Rhode Island this could
have been anywhere in the country it's
just the fact that this is not right and
people need to stand up and make sure
that they're paying attention and say we
don't agree with this this is not a act
that fits within the framework of the
Constitution and they need to say
something right I think that's the that
that's the really really big thing to
all this control to have the idea of the
digital dollar competing absolutely
control the population yeah speaking of
you know the digital dollar absolutely
one of the risks of moving to a cashless
society is that there will be a very
high probability of increased
surveillance right a minute that's what
ends up happening
but again I think that you know that
there's pros and cons to everything and
in the United States historically we've
had a much better track record than I
think other countries like China etc now
we're not perfect by any means and
there's incredible concerns around how
data is used how tracking is done and
kind of that surveillance component and
so people need to understand the risks
and rewards of moving to that cashless
society with a digital dollar but but I
do think that it's going to happen
whether whether we want it to happen or
not and to is there are some pretty
significant advantages around
accessibility accessibility to the
dollar etc that people can gain from
this if they go ahead and do it so I
think we're gonna see it happen but but
we'll we'll see what happens there pop
stop complaining desperate times call
for desperate measures
stop spreading outrage listen I couldn't
disagree with that more that's the
dumbest argument that I've heard right
oh you know desperate times call for
desperate measures
no they [ __ ] do right that's
absolutely not true
violating the American Constitution is
in a kind of sort of sometime thing
right the Constitution doesn't say this
applies except for when the government
says that it doesn't need to apply the
Constitution is there because it's the
rules it is the set of rules which
govern the relationship between the
government and the citizens and nowhere
in there there's no footnote there's no
asterisk there's no anything that says
oh this applies except for in desperate
times that's not how it works so
desperate times don't call for desperate
measures
that adds complete [ __ ] what it
means is the United States constitutions
they're if you don't like the rules
change the rules but you ain't gonna be
able to change the rules because the
rules are there and they're good and
they're there for a reason right and so
we have we live in a democracy we don't
live in a dictatorship where the
governor just signs an executive order
and decides that she's gonna violate the
Constitution that's what happened
literally the governor signed an
executive order so I
all action to violate the Constitution
at the state level so it's not
acceptable right and so it has nothing
to do with desperate times call for
desperate measures act it's actually the
exact opposite in desperate times
Americans need to pay attention and call
out this nonsense let's see here let's
see what else you guys disguise that
emergency they will use Necessary and
Proper Proper Clause definitely not cool
yeah again they're gonna end up using a
health crisis in order do their best to
try to erode civil liberties right and
look by the way I don't actually think
everyone who tries to do this is
malicious I think there are some people
who believe that desperate times call
for desperate measures argument I just
think they're wrong and so people need
to say something I've got a big platform
and that's what I'm doing right now so
any evidence of this photos of anyone
who knows who got stopped if you look at
this I'm gonna drop in the comments here
a link that link has photos in it of the
police stopping cars I believe I'm sure
that there's there's other photos
elsewhere though if New Yorkers didn't
abandon ship it wouldn't have come to
this I just don't agree with that right
like again it is your constitutional
right to go wherever you want within
this country you have no ryu have no
idea what those people are doing right
you have no clue why they're going
somewhere actually in many cases they
may actually be able to get into a more
secluded quarantine area right if you
have a vacation home for example and
somebody's leaving New York to go to
their vacation home to get away from
people that actually may be a positive
thing right but what I know for sure is
not a smart idea this would take police
remember in New York City 500 New York
Police Department officers and members
have tested positive not 500 think they
have it they've tested positive for and
so you have 500 people just in New York
on the police department that have
coronavirus well what happens in other
states when you have the police
department and they have Corona bars and
they're going house-to-house searching
for people right social distancing is
just as important for the police
and for health care workers as it is for
everyday citizen now of course there are
situations where the police have to
respond to calls for help the healthcare
worker has to attend to a victim but
newsflash look at how many doctors and
nurses are dying in the United States
from coronavirus it's a high number
right this isn't like oh there's one
person one time I mean so these people
are just as susceptible as you or I are
and having them go house to house is an
stupid idea
the police in military do not comply
yeah look I have no clue where the line
is I'd like to believe that if you know
police officers and military were given
unconstitutional orders or things that
would violate the Constitution they
wouldn't comply I have no clue by no
means am I saying that they should do
that now
but but it's definitely an option for
them but but I just think that that this
entire situation is pretty absurd and
people need to say something
because I think that that's the only way
that these situations actually rise to
the top and people realize what's going
on let's see here
borders yeah look there's absolutely
state borders I have no doubt that the
state borders exist and I fully
appreciate state rights actually I'm in
favor of state rights in many cases but
but again being able to shut your
borders to American citizens is
obviously not gonna fly the governor of
Rhode Island's two lawyers told her that
and so instead she then decided to use
the National Guard and police to patrol
her state and to go house to house and
to pull over people it's just what's the
difference between pulling over somebody
because of the state license plate that
they have versus you know any other type
of profiling right or any other type of
you know just a pulling something over
without probable cause right it's all
the same thing and yeah they can use the
oh it's a health crisis all they want
but that's just a lame excuse to break
the rules right that's all that ends up
being and
I think we have to call that out let's
see here what else mmm do you not think
they are taking protective measures no I
don't think they're taking protective
measures if you look at most of the
officers that are walking around you
know here in New York and in other
places they don't have PPE on right and
part of that is because what they're
trying to do is instill confidence in
the population all right they're not
walking around masks on they're not
walking around with gloves on their
hands it's actually the opposite they're
intentionally not doing it so that they
can keep confidence in the population I
hope that they would right it would be
amazing if they would but again you have
to remember there's a shortage of PPE in
a country and then you've also got the
confidence things I don't think that
most police officers or if you if you
pulled police officers in the United
States and said how many of you have
worn PPE while on patrol you know in the
last week I bet you less than 50% of
them and so I just don't think that
those protective measures are there and
you know kind of the way that they
should be it's a very fine line to walk
you're right look that this is there
there's no right answer here right I
think this is a really key part of this
there's absolutely no right answer to
this problem but what I in this problem
being the Cova 19 or coronavirus you
know kind of spreading but what I do
know is we have frameworks to think up
solutions and those frameworks include
things like the Constitution right and
so we can't overstep the bounds in order
to quote-unquote
come up with a solution but newsflash
this isn't a solution this is actually
even worse than that right imagine if
you're a Rhode Island resident and the
cop knocks on your door well what do you
open the door
because all of a sudden now you're
exposing yourself to risk to somebody
who's been knocking on everyone else's
door it's just it's just a dumb solution
for a problem and so I think that this
just needs to be rethought here
let's see how do we get them to do the
right thing yeah look I think that again
people talking people
calling this out is is how you change
this somebody said I'm actually
surprised there's no civil rights
organization challenging these
government lockdowns in court again look
the the government locked down stuff as
far as I've seen for the most part they
are asking people to stay home or
heavily encouraging people to stay home
I think there's a couple of examples
where they've basically said you know if
you don't stay home you can get a ticket
and things like that so I'm sure
somebody will do it out that that's not
my kind of hild to die on at the moment
but but the idea of using the police and
the military to not even just enforce
the stay at home you know kind of idea
but instead using the policing military
to go seek out American citizens to
question them to pull them over to
threaten them with monetary fines and an
up to 90 days in jail that's where we
got a draw the line say hey what's going
on here right why are we allowing people
to do this I just don't think that's um
that that's something that we should be
okay with it's almost as if medical
professionals should be making these
kinds of decisions yeah look I I think
that we definitely have a lot of medical
professionals right now that are doing
their best they're trying to inform
people but the problem with the idea
that only medical professionals are
making these decisions is that the
medical professionals have no experience
with law enforcement with economics with
you know City Planning with logistics
outside of the healthcare industry etc
and so I actually don't think it's just
healthcare officials who should be
making this decision I think that it's a
collection of people from different
disciplines right if I was a healthcare
professional and an expert you know an
epidemiologist or whatever it is and I
had an idea as to how this would spread
what I would want to do is I would want
to talk to other experts from other
fields to come up with a plan together
so I don't think it's just that only
healthcare experts should make this
decision I think that this is something
that you know people should make to get
there because I do think that that's how
you you solve these problems
Bill Gates yeah look Bill Gates has been
on top of this for a while
obviously Bill Gates didn't say anything
about you know hey look this is
definitely is gonna happen or here's how
you know that this thing is going to be
the corona virus or the strainer I think
that but he's been saying I think since
like 2015 there's a TED talk of him
talking about how we're unprepared for a
pandemic or a virus and so I think that
it's pretty interesting that he's been
so far ahead of it and obviously he's
incredibly intelligent and so any help
that he's providing I'm a huge fan of
because I think he really does that does
understand this and is is hopefully able
to get us up and in front of it
am I worried about impending
hyperinflation look I'm not worried
about hyperinflation in the short to
medium term mainly because I don't think
that the United States government or the
Federal Reserve has lost discipline when
it comes to money yes I believe that we
are in a deflationary environment right
now the dollar is getting stronger kind
of every other assets getting sold off
eventually we will move back to an
inflationary environment right though
the market will be flooded with dollars
and and that inflationary environment
obviously has inflation but I don't
think hyperinflation is a concern at the
moment but if they need to continue to
drive more and more stimulus bills which
I think that they will have to do if for
some reason they need to do that then
what we will see is I think that we will
see higher levels of inflation over time
but but in the short to medium term I'm
not worried about hyperinflation I just
think that inflation in general is gonna
be really bad for the bottom 50 percent
of Americans so we'll see
what are my thoughts on neuro-link Elon
Musk company that would be putting wires
and chips and brains yeah look I think
that's gonna happen
absolutely at some point in the future
if you think about kind of air pods
right
we went from landline phones to kind of
the big brick mobile phones to then we
went to the foot
then we had an iPhone and kind of now we
had and then we had headphones with
cords on them and now we've got a
wireless headphone in our ear and so you
kind of get closer and closer and closer
to getting technology you know kind of
streamlining that form factor and
eventually absolutely there will be
technology just embedded in you know in
your body whether it's actually
something like neural link that's
embedded in your brain right kind of a
highly complex highly sensitive part of
the body or something else right whether
it's embedded in the back of your hand
or whatever but I just think that that
is a kind of foregone conclusion the
question is how do they do it when do
they do it was the functionality kind of
what's the trade-off right what's the
risk you take what's the functionality
that's given and then on top of that I
think that there's a huge movement in
technology to look at what's going on in
the healthcare space and then start to
bring that to consumer technology so if
you look you know there's been
pacemakers there's all kinds of
technology that's embedded in people for
healthcare reasons if you can all of a
sudden then start to provide consumer
applications for that again I don't
think this is going to happen next year
but I do think that it will happen over
time and so it'll be pretty interesting
to to see kind of how that happens but
but it's definitely gonna happen yeah
I'm gonna into humans are definitely the
future I don't know how we got to to
augment into humans but yes I definitely
agree that that's gonna happen let's see
what else here
yeah vaccines in the solution for corona
virus so look my whole thing on on the
kind of you know hydroxychloroquine and
and the vaccines or cures etc is I'm not
a doctor I have no clue what works and
what doesn't work what I do think that
we should do is we should empower
healthcare professionals and these
healthcare companies to move as quickly
as possible while maintaining safety to
determine
what is effective and and what's safe
right and so that involves everything
from clearing the regulatory hurdles we
shouldn't say draw down the barriers to
getting something approved by saying
we're gonna lower the standard but I do
think that there's a lot of things that
we can do in terms of speeding up the
development process speeding up the
testing process and really getting kind
of concrete answers that solve problems
which i think is important and so
hopefully we will seem to happen over
time but but I do think that there will
be some kind of solution or something
that mitigates the symptoms obviously it
appears that we are getting closer right
there's a number of tests that have been
done that are showing some things have
some efficacy but then obviously a
vaccine is going to take you know I
don't know anywhere from 12 to 24 months
it sounds like when I when I read
through the things I've read through so
let's just see kind of what happens
there but absolutely I believe there
will be a solution I just got to take
some time to do the testing and make
sure that that we get there yeah the
healthcare industry is definitely under
under a kind of siege if you will or is
in a crisis right and what I mean by
that is there's not just the influx of
patients the influx of patients I did a
podcast this past week with with Jason
Williams my partner who he talked about
the influx of patients is actually in
low-margin revenue lines of business
meaning that when though when the
patient walks in the business actually
doesn't make a lot of money sometimes
even a loss leader for that individual
and so they're not making money on
elective surgeries and other high margin
areas and so we're headed towards this
place to pay if this is like a really
elongated problem hospitals may actually
get into pretty dire financial
situations so that that's one thing to
pay attention to the second is a lot of
health care workers are being infected
and so what you end up getting is
there's things like one do you try to
keep some of your staff you know away to
you have to have PPE
there might be a shortage of it and then
three is I even know of hospitals that
are basically splitting teams and
they're saying there's like an a team
and a B team eighteen works this week B
team works next week and so they rotate
back and forth to try to prevent
everyone getting infected at the same
time right if you can kind of stagger
your staff you have a better chance of
never getting caught with majority of
the staff being infect at the same time
it's I think that there's a lot of stuff
going on in hospitals that we just don't
understand you know the photo I posted
this past week was absolutely
heartbreaking where you've got nurses
that are you know wearing trash bags as
PPE I mean just just so sad that the
people who are on the front lines
finding this from a health crisis
standpoint don't have the tools they
need to do their job and so just you
know thoughts with those people more
people need to be appreciative of what
they're doing but it's it's rather
courageous of them frankly to continue
to do that in the manner that they're
doing it so we'll see yes the trade-off
between civil liberties and the health
crisis is very real I am in the camp
that we should not encroach on people's
civil liberties mainly because it's a
slippery slope there's no single answer
it's a hotly debated controversial topic
I understand but I also think it's
really important for us to call out when
people overstep their bounds right when
people do things that are just blatantly
violations of the Constitution
especially when they used the armed
services right police and military to go
carry out those actions I just don't
agree with that and so somebody needs to
say something and more people should be
you know kind of upset about this and in
trying to contact the governor of Rhode
Island to to knock it off all right guys
I'm gonna do two more questions and then
I'm gonna go go eat breakfast let's see
here my wife is a nurse hospitals are
hoarding Maskelyne gowns limiting one
per shift in attempt
not run out and throttle PPE given out
scary yeah well first of all thank your
wife from from the rest of us that that
she's doing the work that she's doing it
the hospital's hoarding masks and gowns
and kind of limiting one per shift
doesn't surprise me right they have a
limited amount and they're trying to
plan right it's kind of like cash
planning for a business you can't run
out right and same with the PPE at a
hospital and so they've got a rash in
that be very prudent about how they give
it out in order to make sure that they
survive so you know your wife is doing
incredible work and hopefully she she's
safe and the rest of her coworkers are
safe but it's a really really dire
situation so we'll see here see what
else take one more question and I'll get
out of here yeah Congress in the house
can sure pass things when they want to
yeah so here's the here's the crazy part
right is what we just saw was classic
politics where there was a bunch of
negotiating there was basically a bunch
of you know hype and arguing and all
this nonsense and then the bill we got
has got a bunch of the same nonsense in
it as you would expect right there's a
lot of value for rich Wall street-type
corporations or you know businesses
you also get some help but not nearly
enough help for individuals and small
businesses and then on top of all of
that there's a whole bunch of garbage
thrown in there and all the pork that
gets thrown in I think is something that
people just are aware of right we know
that politicians do this stuff and this
was no different and so they're
celebrating the fact that they got this
two trillion dollar stimulus package
passed but again if you're willing to
print trillions of dollars how much
money would it cost to you know pay one
student debt or feed the hungry or house
the homeless and so I think we just have
to remember you know this is how a
society works is how an economy
works it's not something that is ever
gonna change but just kind of staying
aware staying alert understanding the
environment that we're in and
understanding you know a lot of the
jockeying if you will in politics is
simply that it's jockeying right it's
not about getting the thing in front of
them done it's about something else
they're campaigning or they're
negotiating you know for the next time
or whatever it is and so I'm very happy
that they got the stimulus package done
I think it was important for them to get
done I think that there's a lot of
people who are hurting and they need
help but you know as I tweeted yesterday
I think people are misinterpreting the
current unemployment situation the
numbers that came out this week
you know 3.2 8 million Americans filed
for unemployment leading us to jump from
three and a half to call it five and a
five and a half percent unemployment in
United States I don't think that numbers
accurate I don't think that numbers even
close to accurate my guess is that right
now we're closer to like eight to nine
percent unemployment and some of the
examples are you know in the state of
New York I believe it was that there was
1.7 million Americans here who's just in
New York or New York in Texas 1.7
million Americans called trying to file
unemployment claims and about 200,000 of
them ended up making it into the report
and so there's you know if that if those
numbers are accurate which again I
they're probably not they're
directionally correct if if those
numbers are directionally correct you're
talking about you know a million and a
half people right there just in two
states that we're trying to file
unemployment that can't also if you look
at like freelance workers right who have
jobs but all of a sudden all their jobs
dry up yet technically they aren't part
of that unemployment number but they're
unemployed that they have no work they
have no income and so I think that we
just got a you know again just be super
super kind to people right now do our
best to help as many people as we can
but also realize that it's pretty dire
situation and I think that there's a lot
that people need to unfortunately
take
time before this stuff services and we
realized the real gravity of the
situation we're in but going back to
finish up on the the rhode island thing
the answer is not to use the military
and the police to go door-to-door the
answer is not to you know target people
based on what state their license plate
is from and the answer is not to go to
certain neighborhoods because you
believe that that's where vacation homes
are and to again go door-to-door or to
stationed the military and the police
had centers of transportation so you can
question people it's just I just don't
think that's a world that we want to
live in I think it's a very very
slippery slope and ultimately I think
that we can do better right with better
leadership we can do better and so
hopefully that happens over time but
hope each of you had a great week given
the circumstances and you have a great
weekend I will almost talk to you guys
soon